- Wait, so what was
your ride or die moment?
- Oh gosh, this is a little
bit of a tear-jerker moment,
but I had breast cancer
about six years ago now,
and this one summoned me
in the middle of treatment
to the Four Seasons where she
was using as her Starbucks.
(ladies giggle)
We didn't have any money
- I wasn't welcome there.
- We didn't have any money,
she would take a table
and just order sparkling water,
(ladies giggle)
and answer emails.
So she said, "Meet me
at the Four Seasons",
and I showed up,
- I love this.
- I said, "Listen," I go, "June,"
and I don't know why I felt like June
was the authority on my health
when I had some very good doctors,
(audience laughs)
but, I said, "June,
do you think I'm gonna make it?"
And she goes, just like regally,
she probably was in a blazer.
(lady giggles)
She goes,
"Oh, I have no question
you're gonna make it.
What I'm interested in
is your mental health,
so I'm gonna-", and I feel
like she took out a Rolodex,
I know that wasn't true,
but she was like, "I'm gonna send
a multitude of healers to you."
And I said, "What?"
Cut to, ding dong.
"I'm gonna lay hands on
you. My name's Ethan."
(ladies laugh)
"I need to sage your house."
"I do witchcraft."
I was like, "Wait, what?"
And that's what she did for me,
and I don't know what it is,
when you ask your best friend,
"Do you think I'm gonna be okay?"
And they say, "Yes" and you believe them,
it really did give me the courage,
to get through the rest of it,
(audience clapping)
and know I'm gonna be okay,
and I am.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
(audience cheers)
- I mean, look.
- She is. Better than ever.
- Better than ever.
- Okay?
- And listen.
- Better than ever.
- When you send over 20 healers,
they're not all gonna be great.
- They weren't all great.
(Kelly laughs)
- Some are gonna be weird.
(Kelly laughing)
Yeah, it's just the numbers
aren't gonna always work out.
- (laughs) The numbers are against you,
but someone will work out.